joining us now a former director of
communication at downing street under
tony blair of course alastair campbell
good to see you on sky news today so
this staunch defense uh by sir jeffrey
cox suggests uh he will leave his fate
to the electorate
in one of the safest seats in the
country uh i mean i i actually cut my
journalistic teeth down in tavistock on
the tavistock times and it's a very very
very conservative seat and this argument
that the tories are pumping out today
well ultimately it's up to the
electorate um it's not quite as simple
as that and the electorate will be they
they choose their mp and they vote for
their party at election time for all
sorts of reasons but the bigger question
here
is when an mp gets out of bed in the
morning and looks at himself in the
mirror or he's doing makeup or whatever
it might be when they're looking in the
mirror who are they motivated for who
are they going out there to work for
and i think people will be absolutely
well maybe not shocked because we know
so much from from some of the other
stuff that goes on but you know how can
he possibly be doing the job that he
should be doing for his constituents
when his priorities so clearly lie
elsewhere and the bigger point i would
make this is this is a situation now
it's about boris johnson what he is what
he how he does his job who he is what
his character is what he allows the mps
to do
because if you have somebody at the top
who has you know very loose moral
standards then that spreads and that i'm
afraid is what we're seeing happening
you may agree then with boris johnson
who has said that mps should be visible
in their constituencies
well mps and particularly prime
ministers shouldn't just be visible they
should be accountable and they should be
held to account and of course boris
johnson is is somebody who hates
scrutiny hates challenge and what this
whole story is about
right back to what we've seen in recent
days boris johnson wants to get rid of
any organization that holds him to
account uh he's contemptuous of
parliament he's contemptuous of the
media uh you know which is from a you
know he was a journalist but he now has
such a contempt but anybody who has some
difficult questions
um so look jeffrey cox is the is the
current um focus of attention but
ultimately this is about
the character
lack of moral probity of the prime
minister and the fact that the
conservative party one by one they go
out there they defend him they say that
he's honest when we know he's not that
he say that he's accountable we know
he's not but they say he has integrity
we know that he when we know that he
doesn't and let's be frank i mean
honestly i see him popping up to
to to glasgow today i don't believe that
he's doing that because he's trying to
bang heads together on uh on the
environment he's trying to look busy and
he's trying to look like he's not got
sleaze lapping around his ankles this is
on his watch and it's his character that
is doing fundamental damage to his party
more importantly the thing that i care
about is damaging the country and our
reputation in the world on the wider
aspect of course it's not illegal for
mps to have second jobs should that
continue
well i think that the
mps are pretty well paid most people
watching this who say they're on 82 000
pounds i think there is you know i look
at some mps who do things outside
parliament and i think some of them
actually are useful both to them and to
the job that they do you know every time
i see rosina allen khan labour mp
talking about the work that she's been
doing in the a e ward as a doctor i know
there are conservative gps who keep
their work up but i think we're talking
about something completely different
here we're talking about somebody who's
making you know some massive six-figure
sums i heard sadja javid defending it
this morning well you know no wonder
because he was on 300 grand from a from
an american bank
and he was asked i heard him being asked
this morning how does that help his
constituents in bronze grove he couldn't
give an answer i think if we heard more
about mps who were doing unpaid work in
food banks and unpaid working care homes
there might be a little bit more
understanding of this so i think we've
got to be careful not to say mps
shouldn't do anything other than bmps
but what we should be able to know is
that when an mp is doing his or her job
they are constantly primarily motivated
by their constituents but if you have a
prime minister who is not motivated by
the welfare and well-being of the people
then don't be surprised if that spreads
to mps thinking well i'm actually here
just to help myself as well
while you're on alistar campbell i want
to ask you not just about your starring
role on countdown at the moment but of
course the news that our sky news uh
icon to many adam bolton is soon to be
leaving us your old sparring partner
well it didn't quite come to blows
um
i think it's fair to say that one of uh
i'm suspect i i imagine that there will
be the occasional replaying of uh
a well-known encounter between me and
adam
uh in the 2005 election campaign 2010 i
think it was uh yeah 2010 may 2017.
what i would say about adam is that i
think he's well we have had our
differences we've had some pretty fierce
arguments down the years but he's
somebody who i respect for his integrity
i think he's got real integrity i think
he works phenomenally hard uh and i
think he's i would say he's hard but
fair
um and i think that he will be missed
i'm sure by people like yourself and
your colleagues i think you'll be missed
by people who watch sky news as well and
i don't think you've been missed by
boris johnson because adam actually does
believe that it's the job of a
journalist to hold the government to
account and told politicians to account
and ask them tough questions and of
course boris johnson doesn't like tough
questions he prefers to hide infringes
widely respected broadcaster you will
agree i would
alison campbell many thanks indeed for
joining us today thank you